and they work it back to the right point shot
in the high slot is blocked but the Ducks unable
to recover possession Michael pin finds Coleman
kicked out by doall Ducks use the boards but it
gets away from strome Hanahan throws it wide
on the short side andah I'm having problems
recovering possession and they just throw it
away at Center Hanan fires it back in So can
they get a change is the big question as now yov
throws it to Center again only to have it picked
off so you get caught out there if you can't
get the puck pack Center ice with possession
that seems to be the Fate right now for Anaheim
Rasmus Anderson gets it to the net gdale looking
for a shooting Lane instead finds Troy Terry back
across dri Dale Chris Crossing with Fowler throws
it on that kicked out by marstrom Leo Carlson
gets it back to Dale at the line and across the
top it's Fowler here's Carlson popping out little
back pass room for Dale one timer from Fowler Mark
him with the save yeah good Puck movement here
and you see how active Jamie Dale is back to the
point saucers it across as Terry came out High to
help now chases to the corner as Rasmus Anderson
has it knocked away there Carlson short little
pass to color back to the line one timer from
Dale and that takes out McKenzie weager in front
as he blocked it and he cannot get back on his
skates so weager is in a little bit of trouble
meantime Conor Zer into the Anaheim Zone allows
weager to get to the bench drops it back and D
Simone scores oh boy Nick D Simone with a one
timer from just inside the stripe Calgary leads
one nothing this comes out of nowhere and Lucas
doal just kind of fan on this there did not appear
to be any kind of a screen everything's going the
duck's way on that last shift and you can see
Calgary enters the Zone a little stop up move
there buying a little time was Conor's a and
I don't believe that Brett Leon was the only
player who just broke into the neutral zone there
they missed the pass but you got to be watching
for that Harry pops out got a shot away gloved
off by March from neither of these teams ahead
for Coleman and backland gets it the rest of the
way in the newly minted captain Oh Ducks turn it
over and there's backin big save doall backin
just named captain in September and he found
himself all alone in front with the puck there
mov with it kind of a cute little carum pass in
the corner and he put it right back in front of
his own neck here's hubero Ducks changing and do
stall again way out to make the stop rosich spins
in the left corner feeds the point weager goes
across the top Anderson with a given go heads to
the net popping out high as roska good movement
in the offensive zone the return pass came right
to the slot Coleman didn't get a lot on it again
the duck fail to clear though cross for Hanahan
Noah Hanahan releases on the puck up the left for
through it in front it's in the gear of doall
who swaps it to the corner so Lucas has made a
couple of nice stops he steps up to keep it alive
and Hanahan broke his stick Fowler with a long
wrist shot blocked it comes back to cam high
slot one timer Henri gloved off by markstrom
Max Jones reaches out to get to it little cycle
play McTavish from the dot through traffic save
markstrom and Jones parked at the top of the blue
paint draws a lot of attention marches through
the logo and into the Calgary Zone on left wing
tries to make a pass in front Ricochet to the high
slot Terry has it and it took a shot boy that
was partially blocked turned into a change up
and it nearly beat markstrom in 97 opportunities
29th in the lead and they work it down low Cadre
with a backhander trying to go short side and may
have gone off the mask of do stall and he covers
up Diego Sharon govic leads the Flames with 11
goals on the season Zer shot locked by lushin
but he gets it back and right of the doorstep
linol denied by Gall that's good stop now roska
drops it off for Blake Coleman wanted to cut to
the middle ran into resistance drops it off and
backman puts it behind the it Coleman stopped by
do stall Point Blank That's great stop that's a
one Tim from inside the has marks and sta got a
good read on it and the penalty to Frank patrono
is over so Calgary 0 for one on the power play
but they lead one- nothing AJ Greer carries in
Martin ppil sends it around rear behind the net
back for Dylan duay right in the goal line he'll
take it behind the net now circles in front fires
and getting the shoulder in the way was doall just
got his head up in time Coleman had him lined up
ducks have numbers the other way and a glove save
by markstrom as it was mov who joined the rush
you know what they're a big team they they've got
a lot of young guys in the lineup and I mentioned
they are a four checking club and so the quicker
you get back to collect those loose pucks got
it over to Leo Carlson he tries to spin back
knocked down fans want a penalty they don't get
Terry gets it into the slot for Carlson and shot
fought off under five to go here in the opening
period PLS lead one nothing a goal is 224 into
the game the difference the first NHL goal for
Nick D Simone who delivers the hit on Cadre and
comes away with the puck Ducks rink wide and stro
takes it away from weager markstrom with a big
save Flames changing but the outlet pass sends
Rasmus Anderson the defenseman deep into the
anahe little back pass deflected into the blue
paint and then popped into the air doall grabs it
off Terry at Center joined by Carlson pulls up
lets it Go and it's absorbed by Jacob markstrom
backland who pulls it Off the Wall back to
the point and Hanahan serves it down low just
putting it right into the side of the net there
was hubero and doall had to be alert tanv winds
it around and a little touch from Ryan stro
clears The Zone Ducks take the opportunity in
the long change second period to get some fresh
legs and Zer with a long drive that gave Dostal
some problems he really pulls it back in and
we hear this from our friends the Wranglers
last year in 72 games he gets to the top of
the slot tries to serve it off and then gets
it back and fires off the angle weager from
out high that didn't get through and Flames
go to the power play and it's the Ducks who
break out short handed the other way Leon
and Carrick Leon takes the shot and went off
of Anderson and wi picked up by Sharon govic
the other way with Cadre filling the center
lane it's lindol he scored s this is a smooth
move by Elias Lyle what he does with the puck
here is really interesting because he gets it
in the middle it's not a hard shot by lenol
coming laid into the zone and and then you
know he just kind of smoothly takes it backhand
to forehand right here backhand forehand gets the
goenda got crossed up and the ducks have a
little trouble with the puck mnov comes in
his backhander is stopped by markstrom and then
there's the pass across the mov just a little bit
behind him hpal Trails the play here's T have and
a big Save By doall The Rebound was in behind him
dry knocked it away what a stop this would be a
very Steep Hill for an W he was terrific in that
period and look at that he he he got a little
piece of it but the after the stick and Jamie
dryel comes in and twice prevents that puck from
going over the line so Dell with the initial stop
but boy oh boy Jamie drives still with a real
nice play Chris tanip goes up the middle and
as it comes out Center Ice it's swatted to the
near boards coming back Leon trying to protect
that puck in his own Zone pocks it up and hubero
scores I beg your pardon it was AJ Greer and with
two minutes left in the game the Flames lead
now is three nothing well that's going to do
it career high sixth of the season for
AJ Greer so Jacob markstrom is going to
win his 200th NHL game with a shut out here
tonight the third time this season the ducks
have been held scoreless and Calgary
gets the win at Honda Center 3 nothing